in my head and in my heart I know that
time is now
that it is right for me for my party and
for the country
and so today I am announcing my
intention to step down as first Minister
and leader of my party
I have asked the national Secretary of
the SNP to begin the process of electing
a new party leader and I will remain in
office until my successor is elected
I know there will be some across the
country who feel upset by this decision
and by the fact I am taking it now
of course for balance there will be
others who will how should I put this
cope with the news just fine
such as the beauty of democracy
but to those who do feel shocked
disappointed
perhaps even a bit angry with me please
know that how hard
and being no doubt this is really hard
for me
my decision comes from a place of Duty
and of love
tough love perhaps but love nevertheless
for my party and above all for the
country